nous sommes toujours en compagnie
d'aurélie filippetti
[Musique]
d'arno klarsfeld
de puig et luc
et nous accueillons notre amitié du
samedi 20 heures ce soir léonard sans
doute bon soir
alors depuis plus d'un an maintenant la
communauté rom cristallise l'ensemble
des dispositifs sécuritaires du
gouvernement
il y a eu le discours de grenoble
prononcé le 30 juillet 2010 par nicolas
sarkozy il y à une circulaire de brice
hortefeux visant en priorité
l'évacuation des camps de roms mais
mises à part quelques secondes au
journal télévisé on ne voit jamais de
rome à la télévision et surtout on
n'entend jamais qui sont ils que
vient-il chercher en france comment
survivent t-il en marche de nos sociétés
pour la première fois l'un d'entre eux a
accepté de témoigner sur un plateau de
télévision bienvenue léonard mais ce qui
évite et vous nous raconter votre
histoire à 20 heures
en france le terme rome désigne quelque
15 mille immigrés récents ou main ou
bulgares mais attention il faut pas
confondre avec les 400000 gens du voyage
qui sont français à 95% par léonard vous
vous êtes né le 28 octobre 1989 ourdi
szczesny oui une petite ville située à
50 km au nord de bucarest exactement
votre père dur du cac était maréchal
ferrant votre mère petrouchka femme au
foyer et vous avez trois soeurs oui au
début de l'ère post ceausescu tout va
bien la fabrication des fers à cheval
pour les bêtes de trait marche à tour de
bras et l'atelier de votre père ne
désemplit pas
chez les sens douai cette époque on
mange à sa faim oui on était bien en
vain on est vivre bien
donc mon père il travaille tout le temps
bien notre le temps du client ouais et
comme ça notre vie c'est plus facile à
gérer l'école et vous rencontrer maria
qui deviendra votre femme et la mère de
vos deux enfants
mais au cours des années 2000 votre père
est rattrapé par l'industrialisation
c'est à dire que dans les champs les
machines remplacent les chevaux donc il
n'ya plus à fabriquer de fer à cheval et
votre niveau de vie s'effondre we dance
à coup il ya plus d'argent et à tout
parce que
d'autres
alors votre père essaie de se
diversifier il fait des petits boulots
ils essayent de vendre des fruits et
légumes ils travaillent sur des
chantiers
il ya beaucoup de monde qui en a plus de
travail tout le monde cherche du travail
il n'y a pas pour tous les maux alors
c'est donc sur vous qui êtes jeunes et
instruits que retombe la responsabilité
de maintenir la tête du foyer hors de
l'eau oui le point janvier 2007 la
roumanie devient membre de l'union
européenne et pour d des gens comme vous
et évidemment c'est une occasion de
sortir de votre pauvreté le premier à
partir c'est votre votre oncle un
mononcle on y va partir en france avec
une douce il s'installe à montpellier
oui et lorsqu'il commence envoyé 200 ou
300 euros par mois évidemment tout le
monde vous regarde en dix ans après tout
si lui fait ça pourquoi tu le ferais pas
et en juin 2007 à l'époque vous n'avez
pas encore 18 ans vous prenez le bus de
bucarest à montpellier doit les
rejoindre votre votre oncle une soixante
dix euros oui on le voyait celui qui
ment et vu la gêne pour aller à
montpellier d'accord en fait quand vous
partez en france il ne vous reste que
deux semaines pour finir votre scolarité
oui parce que mes parents y en a plus de
travail il y en a plus d'argent pour la
payer les transports de continuer mam à
l'école il y en a plus l'argent pour
manger en a plus rien on est obligé
d'arrêter vos études ont fait exactement
là alors vous arrivez à montpellier que
j'étais accueillies par votre oncle et
là vous découvrez en fait que tous ces
roms vivent dans un campement où il ya
des dizaines de familles qui sont
installés là et pour vous loger vous
emprunter de l'argent à votre oncle et
vous achetez caravane qui roule pas sur
ces sites caravane qui est sur des
parpaings une pitite à la vente qu'à
c'est
une misère 70 euros la caravane oui et
là vous mettez au boulot et le boulot
c'est quoi la mendicité est ce que vous
êtes déçu quand quand vous voyez ça ce
que vous pensiez que votre que votre
oncle avait un meilleur travail en
france vous pensiez quoi penser que
j'allais travailler dans le bâtiment
dans le champ qui est oui
j'avais un petit papier et qui j'ai pas
de logement j'ai faim merci de m'aider
avec une petite pièce exactement avec sa
papier on dit oui sous la terrasse alors
votre oncle lui gagne 20 euros par jour
mais vous comme vous commencez vous
savez pas très bien faire mais d'euros
dur oui j'ai vu du rôle d'un moment j'ai
appelé rapide mais mon père j'expliquais
c'est quoi le boulon en france
je le demandais à mes vous et quelques
d'argent des
revenus en mai je voulais revenir en
roumanie parce que vous dites je ne vais
pas rester ici
qu'est ce qui vous dit votre père à ce
moment là mon père il m'a dit pour
l'instant j'ai pas d'où la jungle je
vais voir ce que je peux faire je vais
prêter je vende quelque chose dans nos
maisons pour t'envoyer quelque chose
d'argent d'arrivée ouais
alors voilà la situation vous interdis
de baisser les bras aussi facilement et
vous restez en france nous avait pas
d'autre solution que de rester en france
et de mendier on n'a pas autre chose à
faire de vive ouais alors au bout de
quelques temps vous récoltez vous au 6
20 30 euros par jour ça commence à
marcher un petit peu mieux mais vous
dites si j'étais en roumanie je ne ferai
jamais la mendicité je suis orgueilleux
je ne veux pas qu'on me voit faire ça
tout dit ou parce que mes parents
sont respectés dans mon pays et une
femme il respecté de tout le monde
viard il y en a du travail avant on est
une famille normale pour faire la
mendicité
harmonisée c'est très dur et en france
avait un peu honte de le faire
finalement ici en france
c'est c'est pas paris ouais mais vous
connaissez personne déjà exactement
alors bientôt vous avez les moyens
leonardo faire venir votre père et ce
qui est terrible c'est votre père vient
en france mais se met aussi à mendier
pour envoyer de l'argent à votre famille
en roumanie oui je l'expliquais que ne
soient pas ceux là vous rentrez vous
marier en roumanie avec maria à ce
moment là et en mars 2008 votre père
votre mère votre femme et vos deux
soeurs viennent en france exact vous
vivez dans le camp de roms vous pouvez
tous ensemble on est petite caravane
dans le cadre d'un une
grande microbes 106 yens sens
électricité
la mise et la misère pour vous c'est le
manque d'argent et la saleté 1
et vous préférez ça plutôt qu'être en
roumanie oui
pourquoi sait plus bien mon pays si j'ai
du travail j'arrive plus en france
à peine arrivé en france votre femme
tombe enceinte
vous vous ne voulez pas élever votre
enfant danser dans ces conditions il
devait absolument trouver du travail
mais c'est impossible alors pour
accompagner votre femme en roumanie à ce
moment là oui parce que mon bébé dans
une corde sans sélectivité 106 yens je
crois que c'est impossible de rester
avec un petit bébé ouais dans sa
condition oui à montpellier vos
activités habituelles c'est la mendicité
et puis la ferraille aussi vous allez
chercher exemple la ferraille un peu
partout dans les poubelles dans les
déchets laissés par tous et qui vous
fait aussi du transport
comme vous avez le permis de conduire
vous emmener d'autres roms en roumanie
alors là vous faites 2400 km de route
avec des routes de montagnes en arrivant
qui sont extrêmement
fils il s'avoue rapporte 300 euros donc
vous donner 200 euros à votre femme et
vous repartez à montpellier avec les
sangles en bus
alors le 21 septembre 2011 vous
accompagnez un voisin à toulouse et sur
la route vous arrêter dans un
supermarché pour faire le plein le
voisin en profite pour aller acheter à
manger et quand il ressort du
supermarché il a l'air très pressé oui
il vous dit monte monte dépêche-toi
démarre on s'en va on s'en va en fait
ils avaient volé une veste et comme vous
c'est un quelqu'un qui est plus âgée que
vous vous le respecter et que ça donc je
n'osais rien dire et vous partez tous
les deux dans la voiture c'est la veste
volet exact alors à peine sorti du
parking deux policiers vous arrête là
policier m'a rappelé ici rapidement il
m'a dit comme un chien couche toi je
voulais expliquer qu est-ce que je j'ai
fait parce que c'est pas moi qui fais
une fraction est comme ça il m'a laissé
pas à parler ils voulaient me taper tout
ça
après n'ouvrira commissariat trente
heures de garde à vue parce que la
police considère qu'ils aient eu vol en
réunion sert quand même si vous n'êtes
pas coupable du vol vous êtes complice
du voleur vous êtes envoyé devant un
juge ensuite dans un centre de rétention
à toulouse vous êtes expulsé en roumanie
exact
après quelques jours avec votre famille
vous revenez vous revenez à montpellier
c'est qu'en fait vous passez votre temps
à faire des allers retours j'ai le genou
est alors aujourd'hui j'étends
montpellier oui vous avez un camion oui
vous avez acheté pour faire de la
collecte de ferraille d'une façon plus
efficace
évidemment ce camion voilà vous n'avez
pas acheté très cher y a pas eu de
contrôle technique n'a pas d'assurance
ito et vous dites si j'ai de la chance
je ne ferai pas interpellé avant d'avoir
remboursé et oui alors désormais vous
avez une seule idée en tête c'est
retrouver votre femme et vos enfants
évidemment pris alors vous dites mes
enfants ils grandissent sans moi c'est
pas bien la dernière fois que je équité
j'ai pleuré toute la route jusqu'à
montpellier il vous manque c'est très
très dur à laisser mes enfants sortent
sans ce mois sont grandissants secondes
c'est pas une vie ça ouais
alors non c'est lui que tu renvoies
là-bas
vais exposer le problème c'est à dire la
france n'auront plus ne peut pas
accepter que des gens que toute une
partie de l'europe aille se déversaient
en paris pour aller mendier sur les
champs-elysées ou pour c'est pas
possible il est jeune il en bonne santé
je veux dire il est périlleux quand il
retourne en roumanie les pae pas
exterminer il est pas tué il revient
vers un pays où il est où il gagne moins
d'argent qu'en france mais en même temps
là il a le droit d'aller en france
puisqu'on est dans le dans l'espace
schengen dont ils les roms sont bien vu
mais il faut qu'ils soient en situation
régulière c'est à dire qu au bout de
trois mois il faut qu'il ait les moyens
de subvenir disons qu'ils soient pas une
charge déraisonnable sur les cours les
comptes publics et la france pour non
plus ne peut pas accepter ça vous me
comprenez qu'ils aient des campements
roms des bidonvilles qui soient créés
aux alentours de paris et qu'il y ait
des réseaux de mendicité qui exploite
des enfants puisqu'ils et des mafias
aussi qui secret ça concerne quinze
mille personnes en france comme il ya
quinze mille roms en france aujourd'hui
ils vivent dans des conditions d'hygiène
déplorables
ils n'ont pas à manger ils ne peuvent
pas travailler donc ils sont dans cette
situation où effectivement s'ils
retournent dans leur pays non seulement
ils n'ont pas de travail mais en plus on
sait il ya des il ya effectivement des
pointes de discrimination vis-à-vis dé
retourner normal je veux juste poser une
question tu es rome ouais tu habites
là-bas en roumanie et rêvent de faim et
je vis en france je tiens en france de
mendiants en france d'ailleurs
d'accord c'est comme entendu mes rêves
de pour ça je fais pas d'encre est pas
de crin j'ai fait enfin bref atteint on
vit ou un moins bien mais on crève pas
de ça on ne meurt pas tu entends dans
les années 30 on mourait 200 en france
quand il y avait la grande prairie ça
c'était ou aux états unis on mourait de
faim il faut avoir une fin pour savoir
ce que c'est mais on ne peut pas la
france les pouvoirs publics ne peuvent
pas accepter qu'il y ait des bidonvilles
qui est des enfants qui mendient et qui
veulent les gens et qui donne tout un
chef mafieux qui se fait construire des
villas luxueuses qui nous donne le droit
du travail en france nous ont fait pas
de problème tout là haut mais non
illégale sur cinq ans et 150 métiers qui
sont ouverts d'ailleurs au sol et aux
citoyens roumains il n'a pas tout fait
pour les roux ce qu'il faut dire quand
même c'est que léonard a trouvé un
travail à montpellier dans un jardin il
s'occupait d'un jardin et la patronne la
virée parce qu'elle avait peur de la
police c'est vrai ou pas oui c'est vrai
j'ai trouvé du travail dans nos jardins
j'ai travaillé deux jours la danoise m'a
dit j'ai du travail du 3 mois jai alai
du travail et que deux jours après m'en
expliquer je peux pas continuer avec toi
mais vas-y peut appeler la policiers
parce que tout est pas parce que vous
déclarez pas mais à 150 métiers qui sont
ouverts l'astigmatisme
lui en france nous sommes déjà à cause
justement de tous ces discours de
nicolas sarkozy de guéant et c est là
aujourd'hui vous dites que que vous être
en mai m forcément vous n'allez pas
trouver de travail bien
merci léonard sans doute d'être venu
témoigner
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux